So people often ask me,
do you believe in God,
which I don't,
I don't like that question.
First of all,
it's an attempt to to.
It's an attempt to box me in in a sense,
and the reason that it's an attempt to
box me in is because the question is
asked so that I can be firmly placed on
one side of a two of a binary argument.
And,
and the reason I don't like to answer it
is because a,
I don't like to be boxed in and B,
because I don't know what the person
means by believe or God and they think
they know and the probability that they
construe belief and construed God the
same way I do is virtually zero.
So it's,
it's a question that doesn't work for me
on multiple levels of analysis,
but strangely enough,
just as we were talking,
I the answer to that question popped
into my head.
I act as if God exists.
Now you can decide for yourself whether
that means that I believe in him,
so to speak,
but I act as if he exists.
So that's a good enough answer for that.
Then with regards to these other issues,
the divinity of Christ,
well,
I would say the same problems with the
question formulation obtain what do you
mean by divine and also what do you mean
by Christ?
These are very,
very difficult questions.
Now,
I believe that for all intents and
purposes,
I believe that the logos is divine in so
far as we.
If if by divine you mean of ultimate
value of ultimate transcendent value.
Yes,
it's divine.
It's associated with death and rebirth
clearly because the logo's dismantles
you and rebuilds you,
so that's what happens when you make an
error.
When you make an error,
some part of you has to go.
That's the sacrifice you have to let it
go.
Sometimes it's a big part of you.
It's,
it's sometimes it can be such a big part
of you that you actually die,
right?
Instead of dying and being reborn,
is there something more than merely
metaphorical about the idea of being of
dying and being reborn?
Yes,
there is.
Because those are associated with
physiological transformations.
How?
What's the ultimate extent of that?
That's a good question.
You know,
the question is what happens to the
world around you as you embark,
as you increasingly embody the logos and
the answer to that is we don't know.
We don't know what the ultimate level of
this.
Now the hypothesis is,
and it's a hypothesis that extends to
some degree to Buddha as well.
The hypothesis is that there has been
one or two individuals who managed that
and that in their management of that
they transcended death itself.
Well then you might ask yourself,
well,
what do you mean by transcended death?
Well,
in the case of Christ,
let's assume he was a historical figure
for the,
for the time being,
which I think is the simplest thing to
assume.
Uhm,
I think there is sufficient evidence to
conclude that you could conclude
otherwise,
but I personally,
I feel that there's sufficient evidence
to conclude that.
Did He,
is his resurrection real but his spirit
lives on.
That's certainly the case.
In what sense do you mean spirit?
Just to qualify that,
how well let,
let's imagine that a spirit is a pattern
of being and we know that patterns can
exist.
Independent patterns can be transmitted
across multiple substrates,
right?
Vinyl,
electronic impulses,
air vibrations in your ear,
neurological patterns,
dance,
so all the translation of what you might
describe as a spirit,
right?
It's,
it's that pattern.
It's independent of its material,
substrate.
Well,
Christ spirit lives on it.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's had a massive effect across time.
Well,
is that an answer to the question?
Did his body resurrect?
I don't know.
It is.
The accounts aren't clear for one thing.
What the accounts mean isn't clear.
I don't know what happened to a person
if they bring themselves completely into
alignment.
I've had intimations of what that might
mean.
We don't understand the world very well.
We don't understand how the world could
be mastered if it was mastered
completely.
We don't know how an individual might be
able to manage that.
We don't know what transformations that
might make possible.